[Música]
oi gente essa manutenção 10 anos e hoje
vim falar sobre sustentabilidade e
criatividade
eu resolvi começa a minha apresentação
com essa imagem chocante para chamar a
atenção de vocês
essa foto foi tirada pelo fotógrafo tal
e move um aterro de lixo no canadá
segundo ele foi um registro mais triste
que fez você sabia que apenas 10% do
lixo gerado no brasil esse quadro
corretamente
por isso eu vim aqui hoje para dar
alguns exemplos pequenas ações que
podemos ter para melhorar esse processo
evite usar calmantes descartáveis para
10 anos utilizadas como estes que vão
estar no fui e eu vou dar um para cada
um de vocês
você saber que só no estados unidos sam
conhecimentos podia 500 milhões de
caminhantes que daria para dar duas
voltas mesmo planeta terra
outra dica não mascara o papel é muito
mais fácil e claro quando ele não está
ameaçado até seu próprio suco e eu gosto
disso a comida pode ser mais saudável e
20 embalagens evite que dizer-lhe
delivery de comida
você já percebeu a quantidade de
embalagens que chega dessa casa é muito
lixo para dirigir uma simples refeição
agora vou fazer uma pergunta pra vocês o
que a criatividade criatividade é tentar
fazer desse padrão antes é realizar algo
que não foi feito ou pensado antes
agora eu vou passar o vídeo dessa ig
magnabosco na garota de apenas 19 anos
que desenvolveu um projeto realmente
significativo criativo para o meio
ambiente não seja um gênio renascentista
onde estava a ajuda da minha mãe aguarda
as compras no mercado
muito menos que ela comprava empacotados
naquelas bandas já por isso na escola já
ouviu falar que o isopor é muito
prejudicial para o meu beijo
ele é feito à base de petróleo que ele
não é biodegradável e que pode levar de
150 anos até um prazo determinado para
se decompor falei poxa esse material é
uma coisa tão simples que a gente usa
tanto nosso cotidiano difícil por alguma
outra coisa que eu não quero criar a
embalagem da substituição bandejas de
isopor
mas na embalagem seja biodegradável e eu
fiz isso usando o bagaço de cana de
açúcar da embalagem que é 100%
biodegradável sustentável economia em
baixo
eu espero que um dia as mulheres possam
se ver como cientista ciência também
pode ser feita por pessoas jovens pode
ser feito por mulheres por cento por
qualquer pessoa
eu acho que a gente tem que enxergar
mais nesse papel é possível construir
casas populares com garrafas pets a
garrafa pet anos maiores poluidores do
meio ambiente
aproximadamente 4,7 bilhões delas são
jogadas no lixo por ano
porém a construção civil vendendo outro
rumo a elas
ao invés de usar josé é possível usar
pets que podem saber que são mais
resistentes e custam 30 por cento menos
do que uma casa de alvenaria é possível
reciclar latas de produtos para virar um
revisteiro uma luminária
[Música]
isso é um pouco do que podemos fazer com
que é tratado a todo instante
agora vou passar o vídeo deu e da minha
avó
a gente está contribuindo com a campanha
do lado não é sequer minha vó gente os
lares é trocar de cadeira de rodas e
você pode contribuir de alguma forma a
sociedade
você pode fazer para melhorar o mundo
você é uma pessoa consciente faz coisa e
descubra
antes de comprar algum produto você se
pergunta se realmente precisa dele
você parece o lixo seco só consome e
itens produzidos próximos à região onde
você mora
você perde muito de livre você
conseguiria viver sem canudos ou copos
descartáveis
precisamos inserir no nosso dia-a-dia
três conceitos sustentáveis
utilize o máximo de objetos que você
conseguir
efe ic o lixo que estiver a seu alcance
e reduza o consumo de bebês adquirir
apenas o necessário para sua vida no
planeta e eu agradecemos
[Aplausos]